the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
hey good afternoon everybody it's uh
mike from order flows
and uh you know welcome to today's
presentation on taking advantage of
unusual order flow activity yeah today
was a very interesting day you know
we opened up last night went higher and
then
the rest of the morning sold down and
later in the afternoon
we rallied and basically closed on our
highs so you know it's an interesting
market environment that we're in and you
know what i want to talk about today
is you know some of the interesting
things you know i said unusual
uh order flow activity but you know i
don't want you to think that it's like
you know something backwards like oh you
know what this
doesn't make sense that it's so rare you
know what i want to show you i'll
explain to you what is
unusual order flow i'm going to talk to
you about the best tools to use to see
the unusual order flow
finding hidden training opportunities in
that unusual order flow
and how you the average retail trader
can take advantage
of unusual order flow activity and
again you know just really briefly for
those that first time to one of my
presentations my name is michael voltos
and
for the last five years i been the owner
and trader at orderflows.com that's my
company that i set up
after i left uh jp morgan where i was
there for eight years i was vice
president of futures trading
and before that i spent four years with
the big commodity trading firm
cargill right i was a trading desk
manager i worked in chicago and
eventually i moved out to singapore
to set up a trading desk there when the
exchange closed the trading floor
and prior to that i spent three years at
commerce bank in chicago as the licensed
ux trader i was only one of a handful
of traders in the united states that
was licensed to actually trade the urex
contracts like buns bobble
shats dax euro stocks and you know in
those days you either had to go through
a broker or
unless you had a license from your ex
you weren't allowed to trade it and we
had our own terminal in the bank and i
was literally
one of a handful of people that had that
license is was able to trade it
and before that it's been a couple years
at edf man which is also a big english
commodity trading firm
you know they trade everything around
the world just like cargill you know edf
man started in the 1700s
as a sugar trader prior to that
i spent three years at dean witter
reynolds
i started on the cme floor as a runner
with dean witter reynolds i started
literally at the bottom
in the industry i mean i started you
know i realized that this is the
industry that i wanted to be in
how do i get started and in those days
there was a trading floor that you can
go down and get a job
literally at the lowest rung and work
your way up which is what i did
i left the floor after about a year and
a half and
i went to trade on the upstairs training
desk when the electronic trading started
taking off with
cme globex the cbot had
project a nymex had
access and you know i i just saw that
the future was going to be electronic
and i wanted to position myself for that
so like i said you know i left
jp morgan after eight years i left there
in 2013.
and you know i wanted a way to give back
to the trading industry that's been so
good to me right i had a very successful
career
and so i started writing a book on
trading order flow you know which is
what i've learned
over those 20 years as trading as a
institutional trader
if you stick around to the end i'm going
to show you how you can get a copy for
free you can download it you can get the
pdf you're not going to get
the hardcover copy sent to you but you
know the pdf is fine you can put on your
phone your tablet or you can print it up
and keep it handy and you know like i
said after i left jp morgan i started my
company
order flows.com which is a software
right that runs on ninjatrader eights
and
the reason why i started it is because
i was trading for myself after i left jp
morgan
and i was using order flow but the tools
that were available
for the trader was just basic tools
right i know that
you know computers exist to make your
life easier and i said you know instead
of me doing these calculations by hand
or
you know in my head on a calculator let
the computer
highlight what's happening in the order
flow to me so i created the order flows
trader software now it runs on
ninjatrader 8 before it was ninjatrader
7.
um it's a volume footprint chart i
didn't invent the volume footprint chart
but i like to think
you know i sort of took it to another
level right steve jobs didn't create
the mobile phone he created the iphone
which is a mobile phone
at a higher level and i have seven
pre-programmed order flow indicators
in my footprint chart and the reason i'm
talking about this is because you know
the charts i'm using in this
presentation
are generated from the software that
the order flows trader software and
again you know the big advantage
of having an order flows software
especially specifically mine is because
you don't have to do the calculations
let the software do it for you
okay this is 2020 your computer should
be doing a lot of the hard work
and you know in the past right trading
software
just processed data and packaged it for
the convenience of seeing where the
market was trading you know a simple bar
chart where
traders could draw trend lines calculate
pivots plot moving averages etc
what was lacking in the software
in the past is it did not present the
data as market information
right so that and what do i mean by
market information is is information
generated from the buying and selling
that's happening in the market as
opposed to
the market opened up here you know at
seven traded up to nine
had a low of six and closed at eight
okay
what you wanna see as a trader is you
wanna see well okay yeah the market
opened up at seven
there was some aggressive buying that
moved it up to nine that stopped it got
shut off maybe there was some volume up
at the high
to push it back down one traded down to
six but down at six you know maybe the
market rejected the trading at sixes and
we closed you know sort of unchanged at
eight
and you know that's important because
you know as a trader you want to know
what's happening in the market
now this is a volume footprint chart if
you're unfamiliar with it
and basically what you want your
software to do is put it into an easy to
read format so you could make informed
trading decisions
now a lot of the charts that are in this
presentation or actually all of them
just you know within the last 24 hours
so you can see you know i'm not going
back a week two weeks three weeks to
find you know the perfect chart i'm just
showing you stuff that happened within
the last 24 hours you know either
in the night session today's session
this is um the 27th of may
or yesterday the 26th now again you know
i got to go through a disclaimer because
you know people think that you know
trading
you know they could take a thousand
dollars turn it into fifty thousand
dollars
in 60 days no
you can't unless you you know get
super lucky you buy an option or
something and the market just explodes
but you that's not going to happen you
understand the trading involves risk
okay
past performance not necessarily
indicative of future results but more
importantly only risk capital should be
used for trading
and only those with sufficient risk
capital should consider trading now
order flow what makes it so important is
because it shows
the direction of the market but a lot of
people they don't know where to begin
with order flow and
like i always tell people right there
are
three basic building blocks of order
flow analysis delta point of control and
imbalance
and i'm going to talk about briefly what
each of those are just so
you know you have a an understanding
right it's like learning to walk right
before you could learn to walk you got
to learn how to
balance yourself and by understanding
delta
imbalances and point of controls that's
going to give you you know sort of that
foundation so you can start taking those
steps forward
now delta is the difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar
delta is important so you know who is in
control of the bar
now every bar is going to have a delta
it might be positive it might be
negative okay
and it's going to appear on my software
at least
on the bottom of the chart okay so you
can see some bars have positive delta
some bars have
negative delta okay and again it's the
difference
in that bar between the net aggressive
buyers
and the net aggressive sellers and
what's an aggressive buyer is someone
that lifts the offer
someone that buys the current offer and
buys into the next offer
an aggressive seller is someone that
sells into the bid and then sells
probably into the next bid so once you
understand
that then you can start to understand
you know how the markets move
and the next point i'll talk about is
point of control and point of control in
a bar is the price level with the most
volume
what you do is you take the volume
traded on the bid at a price and the
volume traded
on the offer at the same price in a bar
and if that price has the most volume
it's your point of control
right it's no mathematical fancy formula
um you know algo thing that some people
you know
that's like the the buzzword nowadays is
i'll go this i'll go that
no it's just basic simple arithmetic
every bar has a point of control here i
just highlighted a few of them
right you can see every bar has this
rectangle this is the price level
in the bar where the most volume traded
and
that's important right it's because you
know most people
when they come to the markets right
they're just familiar with a candlestick
chart or a bar chart seeing where the
market opened
where the market closed they're not
taking into account volume
and volume is very important as as
you're going to see
later in this presentation now the third
thing is
market imbalances and they occur when
there are more aggressive buyers than
sellers
or vice versa more aggressive sellers
than buyers
in the two-way auction so a buying and
balance occurs when there are at least
four times as many traders buying the
offer
than traders selling into the bid right
remember the markets move in a two-way
auction it's
six bit at seven right we don't trade at
one price there's no it's not a fixed
market
fixing you know in the sense like like a
gold fixing where you know they just
take all the bids and offers and sort of
collate them until everyone agrees and
everything trades at one price no you
know the markets move up or down
in a two-way auction at six bit at seven
then the seven straight out now it's
seven bit at eight
and then eight bit at nine etcetera as
it's going higher now
when you have an imbalance it means when
you have four times as many
traders buying that offer than selling
into the bid
when the market is six bit at seven so
you know if it's six bit at seven
and you have you know 100 traded at
seven
but only ten traded at six you'd
consider that a buying in balance now
selling a balance is the opposite
it's when they're at least four times as
many traders selling
the bid and traders buying the offer now
this
four to one four times as many it's not
fixed in stone you could use whatever
level you like most traders use four to
one some use
ten to one some use five to one a few i
know use three to one
you probably wouldn't use two to one but
you know you wanna find
an area where there's more buying than
selling or more selling
than buying now not every bar is going
to have
an imbalance now software can highlight
it to you
right you can see here where the red
numbers inside
the footprint these are selling
imbalances right
the blue numbers inside the footprint
are buying and balances
now you're going to have instances where
you have multiple you know you have like
three or more
selling imbalances stacked neatly on top
of each other
that is a stack selling a balance if you
had three or more
buying imbalances the blue numbers
stacked neatly on top of each other
that is going to that's what's called a
stacked buying imbalance
and you know when you see stack buying a
balance of stacks on imbalances that's
important information
as well because that's going to tell you
where there's potential resistance
or support in the market now the best
way to think of imbalances
is you know like a seesaw right this is
an old postcard
i love um you know
mark is trying to find balance but if
there's one side is heavier than the
other
generally it's going to go in that
direction so
like i said generally as markets rise
you see buying imbalances
aggressive buyers are lifting the best
offer and looking for the next best
offer
demand is present generally as the
market falls
right as it goes down you see selling
imbalances aggressive
sellers are selling into the best bid
and looking for the next best
best bid to sell into supply is present
now one of the interesting things
about trading nowadays is is i find
you know a lot of engineers a lot of
programmers
people from engineering backgrounds
programming backgrounds they're
naturally attracted to the financial
market because they see it as a problem
that can be solved
right they think um you know they can
just use math to solve it right math is
never wrong
right indicators are never are based on
math so technically
an indicator is never wrong
right you know all an indicator does is
solve a math problem
and right or wrong that's the sole job
of an indicator
is to solve that particular math problem
at that particular point in time
but doesn't tell you anything about the
market so
what order flow allows you to do is
it's not asking you to solve you're not
trying to solve the market
it's helping you understand how the
market is acting right now
and most of the time the market does
what it's supposed to do which is
facilitate
trade right that's why markets were
created they were created to facilitate
trade between you know farmers and you
know sort of risk takers
so they could transfer risk and
what's most fascinating is when the
market doesn't do what it's supposed to
do and exhibits what i call
unusual market activity and to order
flow traders it's actually not unusual
but it's unusual to the uninformed
trader
so what is unusual order flow activity
well
earlier i was just talking about
imbalances and i mentioned the markets
go up on aggressive buying and markets
go down on
aggressive selling well what happens
when the market goes down
when there's aggressive buying right or
when the market goes up when there's
aggressive selling
right that's kind of strange don't you
think so this is
a gold one minute chart right this is
from yesterday morning
right now yeah you can see how the
market um
where are we here we we hit that low at
right and then we rallied up right
people will say well
yeah you know you had this pin bar
and you know the market went up you know
that's that's what caused it
we had a pin bar here market you know
went up and fell over again
um you know you could make these
arguments that you had some candlestick
formations here as well
well you know that's all well and good
but if you know as a trader
you want to understand what's happening
in the market
and right at that low in the gold right
here
at 905 you have a stack selling a
balance now
mikey just said when i see a stack
selling a balance it should be bearish
well yeah all right you can see the red
bars got stacked selling and balances
right in here as the market was going
down
what's happening here is the market
opened up
we traded lower there's still aggressive
selling but conditions changed in the
market
right now if you're just looking at a
candlestick chart you're going to say
well yeah you know we
we close higher so you know we probe
down here we look for stops there's no
stops there
um now we're trading higher you're just
guessing
basically you know just as you'd be
guessing right here
right or even right here
but really what you want to be looking
for is what's happening in the market
by looking at the order flow so you can
see here right at this low yeah you have
a stack selling a balance market
rebounded up so price is being rejected
down here
the next bar we got a big selling
imbalance in here
244 right so what happened right this
market closed up here
it was at 17 11 30 opened up
traded lower it was met with some strong
support
in the market got through it a little
bit but
you know it couldn't get any further
past that support area
market rallied up all right now there's
a few other
imbalance reversals you have one here
you had one here
that's what these red and green arrows
are imbalance reversals actually
so you can see here right you have the
imbalance reversal here eight against
61.
you got a bearish point of control there
market sold off right came off
came down to where where you got
imbalance reversal market went up
couldn't sustain that move came down you
got another imbalance reversal start
going up
you're seeing this unusual activity
right the selling of balance on the
green bar
selling a balance on the green bar 114
244. these are big volumes
for gold right if you look at the volume
in all these bars 114
do you see anything over 100 here's 104
nothing nothing here's 101 then over
here the next bar 244 so you got someone
actually
supporting the market here buying 114
another person buying you know another
240 here
supporting this market as the market's
moving up
now in the e-minis
this was yesterday about 12 30.
you see the market sold off right from
you know the 11
and a half area down to the 08 area
but if you're looking at you know a
simple bar chart
nothing stands out you know honestly i
can't even i look at these
candlestick charts nowadays but they
really don't give me much value but if
i'm looking at a footprint chart
well i can see here right i've got
imbalance reversal
right here at the high right we have a
stack buying and balance okay that's
what you want to see as the market is
going up going up
up up there's a big offer there market
gets through it
big offer here market gets through it
comes off pokes up you know one tick
higher through the high of the previous
bar
before it sells off and again
you know that only gets one tick past
this level
where you're running into these reversal
areas
you know so you know you get short right
you're risking what a point
you know short at 11 stop at 12 it only
comes up to
11 and three quarters and sells off down
to the you know eight and a half area
you know pretty quick that's about 15-20
minutes
and again what happened right
there were signs in the order flow of a
market reversal so you have aggressive
buying
met with aggressive selling
as it's starting to come off you can see
the selling imbalances but more
importantly
all right if you know i understand that
looking at these
numbers in the bars can be a little bit
intimidating for people
but if you're watching the delta okay
what's going on market is rallying up to
this swing high up here
okay we get up to um
you know 12 right here 11 and three
quarters
delta is small it's eight it's eight
what's that telling you and how's the
volume it's average decent
eleven hundred there's two thousand one
100.
you get up here aggressive buyers coming
in right because you can see the
imbalances
so why isn't the market going higher you
got imbalance and balance
in balance or you got this nice trend
line actually of imbalances
why you know volume i'll show you a
delta of
8 is telling you that even though we're
going here there's sellers coming in
right
you should be looking you know if there
wasn't active aggressive sellers selling
into the bid
right because remember delta is the net
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers so if you've got
you know 500 people buying the offer
versus 100 people selling into the bid
right that's going to give you an
imbalance right a bind and balance
but and you're going to look at the
delta and say well it's a
delta of 300 instead you're seeing a
delta of 8
and 8. so i know that
even though i see the buying and
balances the aggressive buying
there's also aggressive selling in the
bar it's not showing up as an imbalance
in here like the 449 against 182.
um you know or this bar is a little bit
more spread out but
most importantly in this bar even though
you know you see this buying and balance
you think well you know
the buying balance market should be
going higher but there's also
strong selling strong aggressive selling
that's hidden
in there right you only got eight in the
delta then the next bar
we poke up one tick higher close down
again delta of
eight on volume that's twice as much so
it's telling you
people are happy to transact trade is
being facilitated
at this area even though we're going
higher
you know as you go higher you expect the
market to keep going higher right but
what it's telling you is
aggressive sellers came in to shut off
that aggressive buying
that was going on now
this is what i call an imbalance
reversal and
it occurs early in a bar formation but
you know what what traders get lost on
because they're just looking at simple
open high low close bars or candlesticks
is
conditions change mid bar right a bar
that started out bullish early
but changed during the bar formation and
turned bearish right or vice versa
right maybe a bar started out very
bearish early right we've all seen these
bars
you see these big down candles oh my
gosh i can't get short but by the time
the bar closes it's a green candle
it's turned up right traders oftentimes
overlook that part right and what that's
what makes imbalance reversal so
powerful is because it takes that
footprint that's left early in the bar
right at one point there was very strong
buying you're cu you want to know that
information
um and it it sort of
splits up the bar in like i won't say
chronicle
chronological order but it's basically
sequencing the market
as time prints right where traders a lot
of times fails they fail to put
market context into how a bar forms
right they're just looking at open high
low close
and not the context of the bar's
internal
fluctuations so for example right here's
a mini dow right this is a one minute
chart from yesterday morning
right going up making you know keep
going higher higher higher
you have this nice stack buying and
balance and the bar closes down
i mean it's not a red bar but you know
we close off our highs
then the next bar we open up again we
trade up towards that high
but we can't get past this area up here
and then it reverses and comes down
this is important information if you're
looking at the order flow you know you
got an imbalance reversal going on here
okay market just goes sideways before it
fell over it took about five minutes
before
um you know the the aggressive selling
sort of reappeared and and came back in
and you know if you're just looking at
this you know
you're confused okay well we hit a high
came off
we come back up here what's going on you
know we're going to go higher or we're
going to go down or not
you know it's it's a bit wishy-washy
but if you're looking again at the order
flow you see here what's happening in
the delta
right you're up here near your highs
and the delta is minus one minus eight
that's nothing minus one minus eight you
know
this is a one minute chart if it had an
extra one second this could be a
positive ten
or this could be a negative fifteen or
you know a positive 15
it could go either way but if you're
watching what's happening in the order
full you know you've got a reversal
forming up in here
okay so you're just looking for some
sort of trigger to come in
and tell you to get short the market's
not going any higher
now the order flows trader chart will
highlight
this information on a chart for you now
this is
again this is the mini dial yesterday
with just the
imbalance reversal indicator turned on
to
tell you where the shorts are where the
selling is uh where the buying is
and again you know if you're a
short-term trader this is very
useful powerful information you know
sort of keeping you
in step with the market right down up
down up down back up up up
up up and then down down down
you know this is you know why you want
to use software that is going to help
you
in your trading now another form of
unusual market activity
that you that helps you spot things in
the order flow is what i call market
sweeps right and
you know a big karate kid fan um
there's that line in there sweep the leg
johnny and we just always say that on
the trading desk
you know when um you know sometimes
people would call out hey where's you
know where's the market in crude oil
yeah you say 77 bit at 78
you know okay just you know buy me 100
up to 80. sweep the leg
but um you know what a market sweep is
it occurs when a trader buys up
through the current offer and the next
subsequent offer or sells into the
current bid
and the next bids in the book and this
is done
on one order at one time so for example
right we're all familiar this is a
trading dome
okay what is a market sweep well the
current market is
29 97 75
bid offered at 29.98 okay and
you know the the guy the portfolio
manager
will come in and say buy me 500 minis up
to 29.99
you know he's not really interested and
okay well there's 30 offered at 98 79
at 70 at eight and a quarter 84 and a
half 97 at
eight and three quarters what he's
really looking at okay i can get 100
here
100 here about 100 here about 100 here
and you know whatever's not done
yeah i'll be working a bid there or
maybe someone's got something iceberg
big traders they're really only
concerned they're not concerned about
these little prices they're concerned
with their average price so okay the
market is
97 three-quarters bid at 98. see i could
buy 500
up to 99 that would give me an average
maybe about you know 98.45
you know that you know that's what he's
going to book is his average price
and because he knows that his buying is
going to help move the market up that's
why traders sweep the market
you know i i i do consume a lot of
youtube content from um you know other
quote gurus you know i don't put myself
out as being a girl i just you know put
myself out this is what i've learned
take it or leave it but you know people
say well people are never going to buy
through the offer well
that's crap i used to do it all the time
i know
hundreds of other institutional traders
do it all the time
you know when you have an opinion when a
big trader has an opinion of the market
they want to get in as fast as they can
without impacting the market
and you know if the old man here has got
500 e-minis to buy
and he sees well i could buy 500 up to
99 it's gonna give me an average of
maybe about 98
and a half i'm happy to do it because
i'm probably going to turn the market
bid
99 even bid okay so sweeps happen
um very often in the market and it's
nice if you can see
when they happen now sweeps leave
footprints
in the footprint chart no pun intended
you can see here right this
you got a stack selling a balance and
one of the
ways you can sort of eyeball when a
sweep happens is
if there's not a lot of counter trade
in the sweep because you know what a
sweep is right you're buying or selling
through a level
through certain levels so
there's not going to be time for sort of
the counter trade to happen
right say the market is 96 bid
at 96 and a quarter
you know the person buys it up to three
quarters you know they're just lifting
all the offers so
in that flight when your order is being
executed
there's not enough time for counter
trade
and you know what the software does it
can highlight to you
when there's a potential based on you
know certain criteria when a sweep
occurred
right you see here how this indicating
that a sweep occurred here now
you know during the trading day cash
session
you know 8 30 to 3 o'clock chicago time
um there's a lot of volume that goes
through
there's a lot of high frequency trading
a lot of retail trading
so sometimes it's a little bit hard to
see the sweeps even though they're going
on
it's a little bit hard just because the
amount of volume is just
so great and
sweeps are a powerful indication of
near-term market direction
in but in very liquid markets they're
gonna be hard to see but at nighttime
okay sometimes you know this is why i
talked about seeing unusual
order flow activity right this was last
night around
just you know just before 10 o'clock
right there was a
little sweeping action happening right
here okay
it's hard to see unless you know what
you're looking for
and you know it starts off with you know
obviously imbalances
obviously we got a selling balance here
people say well yeah you got selling
imbalances this should be bearish well
actually what's happened somebody just
came in here bought about a hundred
you know it it's hard to see you're kind
of trying to determine it
that's why i said long ago when i
created myself just let the computer do
the work just sort of
leave that form of analysis out to me
okay
because what's happened is someone you
know it someone just came in and swept
this up
turned it bid here right so you can see
62 is about 30 this is five
and what the reason you have a stack uh
sorry
selling a balance here nine against 23
is because you know someone just bought
it up here turned it bid
right market opened up you know they
bought it up a half a point
turned it bid here some sellers came in
sold that bid that was a little sweep
activity
but look how what preceded it preceded
this big
jump up here all right we all like to
catch these big bars here
right this is a one minute chart you
know this bar went from what three and
three quarters all the way up to
eight and a quarter right there's
probably a sweep happened
right here you know this is what
sweeping looks like where it doesn't
retrace back
and sort of fill in these gaps
you know this one price you know 22 a
certain time in asia
the market just jumped right up there
right but you want to get in before that
happens
and you're going to often see it in the
sweeping activity
earlier again here's another one it
looks
eerily similar but you can see it right
here someone
bought the 28 but 21 that was offered
here turned it bid
right you see the 106 against 62 this
time it's not a selling and balance
then you can see the points of control
lined up right here you only get through
it by a tick
but by this time the person had bought
you know the 100 150 contracts
getting ready for this you know in
anticipation of the market moving up for
you know based on their own analysis
okay
there was a sweep up here this one
didn't work out right just sort of once
you know just sort of backed up on you
came in and filled it up but when you
have a
sweeping activity where it doesn't come
in and retrace it
you know it's going to give you an
indication of potential market direction
you know i don't know you know people
always think that you know when
you know big traders got some sort of
inside information that
you know they got an edge over people no
you know they do their own analysis
and you know and people think that just
because someone has inside information
i'd be trading tens of thousands of
contracts no you know this person may
have
um you know known something
who knows what you know what his contra
you know his
size is only you know 150 contracts so
he's
going all in right goes all in and boom
he moves up from 08 up to 14
in the next five minutes now
if you're looking at a normal bar chart
you're not going to see that activity
right again you know you have these big
moves up this is last night
you have this big move here you have
this big move here
but what you want is what information is
happening
right before that move happened right
you want to be
he'd clued into what's going on here
before
it makes that big move up now
another form of unusual order flow
activities is what i refer to as small
digits or small prints
i just call them small digits i sort of
changed it over the years to small
prints
and what it is it's not your normal
order flow volume
and it's a sign of price rejection or
market exhaustion
and it's basically the market's getting
to a certain level
and trading has dried up you know the
market's going up
but buyers have been dropping off along
the uh
you know along the move up that sort of
hits this high
there's nobody interested in buying nope
sorry i'm not interested anymore
some people i call that price rejection
some people say well the market is
getting exhausted on that move up
you know there's two ways to look at the
same thing and
if you're looking at a normal footprint
chart all right this is what
a normal footprint chart this is from
yet this morning or sorry
today about one o'clock
years ago right i you know before i came
up with my software this is what i would
look at you know it's
like gosh you know trying to read what's
going on okay
i can understand the imbalances i could
understand what's happening in the delta
the point of controls i could understand
but you know what there's
certain things that happen at highs
or when you're trading around highs that
is very revealing
and there's one reason why a lot of
traders struggle to understand order
flows
they don't know what to look for all
right this is why i
i teach you this um and it's what i call
a small print
all right you can see here this red box
right it's a red box red box red box red
box
these are bearish small prints there's
also a small box
small box these are bullish small prints
right small
small and what it's telling me
again this is nothing fancy right this
is just the software
drawing a box around a print
at the extreme that's you know
within a certain range right so this
one's one right
i think i have this one set to nine so
you can see anything that's a
single print one three two
three five six one again
it's not like some algo like oh i gotta
describe it as some alcohol no it's
basically you're just looking at the
order flow okay and it's highlighting it
to me
now this is where your part as a trader
comes in you got to put it in context
with what's happening in the market
okay i hit this high here okay and you
just sort of go sideways
you hit the next bar it trades up to
this uh was that 11
and a quarter 11 and a quarter 11 and a
quarter
it's not a triple top because your top
is here but it's sort of holding this
area
but basically it's gone 366 then 13 okay
then 126 and then one
why one you know is tell me buyers
aren't interested anymore
at this level okay because if there was
buyers still interested it would trade a
lot more than one all right then you see
the selling coming in aggressive selling
38 is selling a balance 270 that's the
selling imbalance right the market
closes down
now points of control right points of
controls are sort of all coming in at
this level
right here you got three out of four
coming in at the
10 and three quarters area you got one
here at 10 and a half but then the point
of control on this part is lower
it's coming in at 10 and a half so okay
well i see you know traders aren't
interested in going higher only
only one contract traded here point of
control is coming in
lower right i see selling imbalances
now the delta what's going on in the
delta right
well we're just kind of going sideways
but delta minus 64
and plus 140 here minus 52
minus 348 okay well
at this point you know you have a small
print you have a delta
point of control imbalances all telling
you
you know there's no buying interest here
right we're putting a lower point of
control
telling you that people are happy to
trade at lower prices
you got negative delta of 348 which is
more than
minus 52 okay so there's more aggressive
selling here
you've got the selling imbalances the 38
the 270
and you got a small print telling you of
price rejection
or exhaustion people don't want to trade
here they're exhausted they're trying to
buy it at
10 and a quarter right then the next bar
you know big negative delta minus 846
one two three selling imbalances in
there
point of control lower but
yeah you could have got short off this
bar but by looking at
the clue was here in the small print
right the people were
tired of trading trying to move this
market higher they tried once twice
three times already
and on the third time there was only one
person interested and the market
reversed
and sold off you know it was a quick
move from
you know ten and a half down to seven
this just happened
one two three four five bars
now yeah when a market is going sideways
right you wanna look for clues which way
are we gonna go
well we're gonna go higher we're going
to go lower and
you know honestly there was a couple
signs here right that
we came in we hit this swing low here in
this bar
at 9 24. the market went up got a single
print here got a couple imbalances
market came
down didn't really test the low
got within a point of the low then it
came back up five buying a balances here
you've got a single print here okay
price rejection now people are kind of
rejecting these lower prices
know it's almost like well all systems
go right well
where'd it go went nowhere right just
went up three ticks
past the previous bar then
the next two bars top of them
single print single print small print of
three a small print of four
right you come down you know look at
this right it's
for for most people they're gonna be
well i'm not sure about it because you
know we came down
and we opened up it's a red candle we
traded lower came back up
next bar same thing we opened up traded
down made you know
a big down wick came back up
for most people that's a sign of price
rejection to the downside
but what's the order flow is telling you
there's actually price rejection
at the top of these bars right right
here and right here
and then the next bar boom down and then
you break out of that sideways action
and you trade you know lower from you
know the mid 90s down into the mid 80s
but you know if you're just looking at
the candlesticks you're thinking well
you know hey these are actually bullish
looking candlesticks
but if you're looking at the order flow
you can see that
there's price rejection in these
bullish candlesticks
now this afternoon or this morning
rather
right we had a big you know just before
10 40 a big
burst of selling right came in then just
went sideways
okay the market's catching its breath
well which way we're gonna go
well the sign was here with the single
print one
right what's happening market opens up
pushes down
comes back up market opens up pushes
down comes back up
goes higher comes back next bar opens up
comes back down trades one contract one
right that's not your normal order flow
right you should be looking at order
flow
you know double digits 34 37 59
40 you know 10 67 32
you know 11 you know bigger numbers
right instead you're getting one
contract
using one contract one contract but
you're getting it
right before that big move up from you
know the 2980 area
up to 29.85 in that one minute bar
right imagine you're getting long off
this you know once this bar closes
you're getting long here
29.80 yeah you got to stop where
78 and a half you know you're risking
what a point point and a half
for what uh the potential you know it
just it moved jumped up five points
right there now again you know
euro currency right you get up to a
swing high small print small print small
print
small print there's a couple more small
prints here i mean there's one
a bullish one here nine but you know
okay
yeah you're not going to just throw all
this bearish
news out because you got one about green
candle with a small print
but it comes right back with a bearish
small print here
stack selling imbalance obviously you
know and the market
you know quickly moved down um
you know 10 full points 20 20 ticks
there
now you know people say oh yeah that's
well and good you know but
you know i don't trade euro currency i
don't trade
um e-mini's i trade 10 years right i'm a
i'm a dome trader
i i scalp a couple ticks here or there
but i trade big size
now 10 years is a contract that trades
big size okay so when you see small
prints
you know in the 10 years you really got
to pay attention to them
because normally at each price level 10
years trade you know what
a thousand you know a couple thousand
contracts at each price level you can
see here there's some volumes you know
this is a four range chart this is ten
thousand contracts twelve thousand
you know there's two thousand five
thousand you have two here right you hit
your low
bounce up a little bit come back down
try to test that low
test is the low but you're running into
a bullish primary point of control and
you might trade two contracts
and then look the rest of the day boom
just straight up
you know this is i don't say gold but
you know this is
information for a lot of people that
you know the trade markets that you know
don't really understand
how to apply volume and again it's
nothing fancy you know you just want to
be alerted
excuse me to what's happening in the
market so
you know let's talk about the tools to
use to see this the the order flow now
you know when i first started trading it
and when a lot of other traders started
trading
you know being complete newbies we all
start at the same level normal
candlestick charts right we all buy the
books
the nissan books you know those big
books that you want to put on your
coffee table look at me i'm a trader
um i could read candlestick patterns so
i got doji here
you know i got a bullish single here etc
but you're not really understanding
what's happening in the market
right you're just looking at a chart and
don't really understand
the underlying forces in the market
because
you're missing out the most important
piece of market analysis and that's
volume
okay so you can see here right you got
this nice deck selling and balance
you got a little bit of sweeping
activity going on in here
right as the market sells off from you
know the 0.607
area down into you know the 96 97 area
and again if you're looking at a normal
candlestick chart
yeah this is where it happened right
here okay
but if you're looking at this you know
there's nothing no big solid reason to
don't want to get short here right yeah
i got red candles got green candles
what do i do but if you're looking at
the volume yeah
what's happening in the order flow it's
going to give you a lot clearer signs
now you know everyone talks about having
an edge in trading and
that's really how you become successful
right just like you know formula one
cars right if it's
a wet track you want to use a particular
tire
right because it's going to help you
grip the racetrack but if it's not going
to rain and you put your tires on
those tires aren't going to last very
long instead of giving you an edge it's
going to
you know be basically an anchor for you
and you know that's why i love order
flow that's why i keep telling people
you know
try order flow and the difference
between order flow and looking at a
normal candlestick chart
is by analyzing the volume because the
volume gives you an edge over the rest
of the traders because they're
neglecting it
and they're treating all prices traded
as the same
and as you can see right not all prices
are being
you know are the same right some prices
you trade a lot of volume
right other prices you trade thin volume
and that's important right and
the thing with order flow is there's so
many edges
in order flow if you know what to look
for or you have software
that's going to highlight it for you and
that's why i created my software because
i wanted something that's going to tell
me
hey you know what there's resistance up
here right
rather than just oh i got a red candle
here okay well maybe i should get short
well one and get short on any of these
other red candles
well this one is telling me this is what
i call a prominent point of control
that's why it's colored
uh magenta because it's telling me
there's resistance
in the market in this bar and as you can
see the next bar right we
opened up at 12 we traded up to where
right to that point of control
came off a little bit more got within
one tick of that area before selling off
more
now what is this one is um
the e-minis again this morning right
having software that helps you with your
analysis
so you can put it in context with what's
happening in the market is going to put
you ahead of a lot of
other traders now this market rallied
um 10 points this morning this is from
the basically the 93 area
all the way up above uh 3 000 and
you're selling off selling off selling
off and then it turns around
goes back up okay but you know people
say well you got to buy the breakout of
the swing
this this lower high well why wait
let the order flow tell you what's going
on and this is
i talked about imbalances before here
you got a mind and balance buying and
balance mine and balance binding balance
now it's not a stacked buying and
balance right which i've shown you
before which has
the imbalances stacked neatly on top of
each other here they're spread out you
got one two three four
but it's coming in right after this low
is made
okay and that's important right this
important information because you know
that
after we came into this low right what's
happened as the market's going down
well everyone is selling but you get to
a point where
it's so cheap that buyers are attracted
right buyers are coming into the market
now
when buyers find something cheap what do
you do they get aggressive right
you go to walmart to buy something and
it's on sale
you probably buy more all right whether
there's toilet paper or whatever
you know because you know that well i
think this
you know s ps i could buy it down here
at 90 92 93
i think it's you know worth 3 000. so
this is the information this is what a
multiple
imbalance bar looks like right the
software can put
a circle in a circle we'll call it a box
around it
so the settings right you know most
people have
an order flow software on their training
software they don't know how to use it
because it's so plain right it's so
generic right does you should ask
look at your software does it show
divergences does it show imbalance
reversals in the order flow
does it show multiple points of controls
in a bar i haven't even talked about
multiple point of controls
if not it's time for you to upgrade you
know does your software show prominent
points of control right which i just
showed you right that
that red point of control does it show
small prints which i showed you earlier
you know if not it's time to upgrade
yourself as a trader
right does your software show unfinished
business does it show
volume and balance does it show multiple
imbalances right i just showed you the
multiple imbalance at a swing low
does it show volume profile does it show
volume ratios
you know if not you know you got to look
to
get software that's going to help you
see what's happening in the market and
that's the reason i created the
overflows trader software is because
the software i was using before you know
which was considered advanced at the
time was just a footprint chart with
very little features other than
imbalances deltas and point of
control but i realized that you can take
that information
and extrapolate it further and make it
mean something
right the analysis i was doing for my
own trading was taking the information
in the footprint
putting in context of the market i
thought you know let the computer
do that for me that's why i created my
own software
and why i ask you the question is if
your software has additional order flow
analysis function
most don't right and to me that's that's
the problem you know most people come to
order flow
they look at it ah you know i don't i
don't know what i'm looking at forget it
and just
throw it by the wayside
you know it's like the people that buy
those big fancy dslr
cameras and put it in automatic mode
right if you're going to spend
1500 on a camera learn how to use it
rather than just use automatic just use
your your iphone for that
and you know if you're looking at
a candlestick chart you're really
limiting your view
and you're making assumptions as what's
happening right now
in the market so for example right why
not give yourself an edge
all right so this is similar to what i
was showing you before
all right market sold off right then you
get down to the swing low
you got the multiple buying imbalances
coming in there right you got that
um sort of the magenta colored box
drawn around the candle
people say well you know here you got
bearish ones you know you had a bearish
one right before it
okay well that's coming after a move
down
right you've already had your move down
what you're looking for now is after
you're coming down into a low you know
is there signs of life that this market
is going to start to rally
one of the first signs of life is that
you're going to start seeing aggressive
buying coming in in the form of buying
imbalances
right so the market just went sideways
basically for two bars
then another bar with multiple buying
imbalances
and this is this is those two bars right
as the markets are
working its way back up
so you know in life just like trading
you're always looking for an edge right
there's more to
it than just being in the right place at
the right time you know honestly you
know my brother is very successful
investment banker and i used to always
tell people well yeah he got lucky he
was in the right place at the right
time you know he you know he went to
he's actually in advertising um before
that
but you know he went to northwestern
business school
and that's you know how he got into
investment banking and you say well
you know if it's because of the school
et cetera it's like
well he put himself in the right place
at
and he put himself so when the right
time came along
but he did the analysis right say okay
well
if i want to be successful all right i
gotta
put myself in this place i gotta be here
at that time
and you know most people just think well
i'm just gonna get lucky and be at the
right place at the right time
now you gotta do analysis to put
yourself there and the market's the same
way
right you need to be here in the middle
of
everything right where so when the right
opportunity comes you're in the right
place at the right time
and you did the right analysis now
this was this morning right after the
cash open in the s ps
excuse me it's a one minute chart right
selling off selling off
come down here it's gonna go sideways
you know hit the swing low
start going up and then just going
sideways but
what's the market telling you right you
say okay well i gotta stack selling a
balance market should go lower
but it didn't it went higher ah mike you
know overflows for the birds
well again you'll take things with in
context of the market
okay yeah i know i got aggressive
selling the market's going down so i'm
not really
concerned with looking at a stack
selling a balance or multiple selling
balances you know at a swing low
i'd be looking at multiple buying and
balances off a swing low but then
okay i look at the other parts of the
order flow well
i see the delta 770 108
132 minus 102 minus 578 minus 1400
stack selling and balance in here okay
do i think this market is getting ready
to rally off the swing low
no i could see delta is getting weaker
you know you had some strong buying
right here
770 then the next bar nothing 108 132
you know people are happy to transact
here you know people are just you know
doing their trading down here
you know maybe people are covering their
shorts
you know maybe there's there's a few
more people getting short here as well
yeah you got the small deltas
and then the the selling sort of
continues right it takes over
right because if this market if there
was strong aggressive buying you
wouldn't have a delta of 108 you'd have
you know
600 700 in each of these bars
but with that bind it's also attracting
selling
right and then the by this bar here with
the delta of
minus 102 the sellers are back in
control
back in controlling x bar minus 578 then
here
minus 1400 so it's gone let's jump from
minus 102 to minus 578. it's
gone five times here it is three times
as much
right so you could be getting short here
at you know anywhere in this bar here
between gosh i don't know um was it oh
six all the way up to o8
and what happens all right you know what
happened right this was today
this is what happened all right we sold
off from the o6 area
all the way down to the 96 area pretty
much straight down
now people will say well mike why is
this market going down on positive delta
okay this is i'll cover this real i
wasn't going to cover this here but
you know this was interesting because i
do want to talk about it is you see
buying and balance buying and balance
some buying and balances
markets go down right because earlier i
said markets generally go
up on positive delta here's a market
going down on negative delta
is it's sort of an advanced
concept i'll say concept of an advanced
thing in order flow is
what you have is people buying the
offers
right so you have strong supply it's
being
supplied here right there's just sort of
this distribution you know people with
supply are
selling out on the offer they're not
hitting
the bids per se you know if they were
hitting the bids that would count as
-1 negative delta so they're happy to
offer it out here
offer it out here offer it out here
right that's causing the negative the
positive deltas
in these bars because people they think
well you know
we hit this area here earlier at 08 okay
and some
buying came in now we're back here at
this 08
you know now we're at 06. people are
saying well you know hey i was buying it
here at 08.
i could buy it now at 0.6 right in here
but there's supply right people are
working offers working offers
so what's happening is you have the
aggressive buyers thinking
you know i was buying it here at a
weight and i could buy those six it's a
little cheaper
but the supply is hidden in here you
can't see it you can see it in the delta
that's why you got the positive deltas
right so the aggressive buyers buy it
and they get tired they stop buying
let the market breathe comes off some
more
now they could buy i could buy it at 02
right so they tried buying it at 02. at
01.02
and then they realized they're not going
higher they'll let it rest you know
they're buying some more
and then the markets just continue on
down once that buying is removed from
the market
because that aggressive buying was met
with um strong passive selling that's
why this market went down
on the positive delta so lastly
you know how can you as the retail
trader take advantage of this unusual
order flow activity well you got to
understand
the delta the imbalance point of control
how to put it together
and the underlying commonality is they
each take into account the volume
traded right you know i hear people talk
about
certain things it just makes me cringe
um you know people say well
you got to ignore the wicks you know on
candlesticks uh you know if you're
drawing lines or stuff because
um you know it's just a probe up there
well
it's not you know you can see here right
look at this green candle you get the
point of control
basically right up here at the top you
know earlier you had another green
candle point control right up at the top
all the volumes happening up here right
and
you know people say well yeah we went up
there we rejected that price well
no we rejected this price because there
was strong selling up in here
right there was strong offers 310 416
when it was bid here they sold all the
224 this 176 the 175.
right that's bearish this is bearish
right here
you know 659 451 648 390. so when this
market was bid
at you know 12 and a quarter it was
strong bid but they were strong selling
into that bid
strong selling into that bid you know if
i can give you one piece of
tip don't ignore the um the wicks
right look at the volume that's
transacted in the wicks it's very
revealing to what's happening
so here's the market right this is
e-minis again this morning
look at the price rejection look at
the small prints here here okay but the
market
so you're expecting the market to go up
but it doesn't it's there's hangs there
and you got the small print here small
print here as the market is going lower
small print here
and it just works its way down you're
seeing price rejection
now what's happening here this is
again this this morning about nine right
mark is
working its way up you got some very
aggressive buying three aggressive three
binding balances here three binding
balances here
then the market just goes sideways you
get up here
to the swing high right delta of three
volume for the bar is four thousand so
it's healthy right it's not like
two hundred it's four thousand so it's
telling me right now this market is
getting to a level
where people are happy to transact so if
you get to a level where people are
happy to transact
once they're done transacting mark is
going to move find that next level where
people are happy to transact
so what am i going to look at i'm going
to look at points of control okay well i
see points in control the next two bars
are
starting you know are almost the same
level it's one tick lower
but you know they are one tick lower i
wait to the next bar or control
one tick two ticks three ticks lower
than these two here so i know that
the market is now starting to find value
at lower levels
i could see the delta is consistently
negative 270 26
negative 270 negative 262 negative 270
okay so if i was looking to trade i'd be
looking to trade it on the short side
and what happens boom next bar opens up
around the 99 area
boom next two bars three bars trades
down to
you know the 93 area you know a quick
three minute move a quick seven ticks
seven points rather
not ticks now
as a trader right any time a market hits
a swing higher swing low you should be
watching what's happening in the order
flow in the volume specifically in the
order flow
and i talked about prominent points of
control earlier right the bearish one
here
and the bullish one here okay so you
have your bearish point of control here
market comes off starts probing a little
bit lower a little bit lower
sort of works its way back up works its
way back up to this prominent point of
control
and then it comes back down you know in
the next bar next part
does get up through it a couple sticks
through it it does violate it
start you know maybe you're thinking
this market's going higher now
and then the aggressive selling comes in
selling imbalance on and balance selling
and balance you got multiple selling
imbalances here
you come in next bar opens up trades
lower puts in all this volume here puts
in all this volume
at a level lower than you know
anywhere the last five six seven bars
you got a
bullish primary point of control there
you've got buying and balance buying and
balance buying imbalance
so you know what was potentially bearish
earlier
is now flipped right it's now it's
bullish
so if you get long right you're getting
long in the next bar you know we're on
the 77 area
all right it starts working its way up
comes back down here it gets down to
you know 76 you know it's a point
against you but more importantly
all right when you take a step back and
you sort of look at sort of the bigger
picture
a lot of people try to look at just
what's happening right in front of the
dashboard but
in the bigger picture right we had a
swing low market is rallying up
got a pullback and in this pullback this
is that
green bar where you had the point of
control that mattered right down in here
right it's coming into a
an area where it's met support
on a move up right if you're seeing
support coming in
on a move up that's bullish right you
know you're getting long at 77
you know next thing you know in the next
20 minutes
you're trading above 80 you know into
the mid 80s 85s
now one of my favorite trades is the
small print at highs or lows
or lows of daily are fantastic but they
could be swing highs or swing lows this
is the euro currency this morning about
three a
four o'clock this morning and this was
the low of the day we put in a small
print here nine it's a five minute chart
on the euro currency
and over the next one two three four
bars
this bar here actually made a new high
or traded up to the high
and obviously the next bar we just kept
going higher so
imagine you know you're buying it in
here you know the low of the day is
what is that um 109 30 i forgot what
that was 37 and a half
yeah you're buying it you know around
what 42.
your stop is just right below this this
small print right here
right and then boom it goes literally
from the low of the day
all the way up to the high of the day
and to new highs in the next
15 20 minutes now
looking at just a plain candlestick
chart this is where i get into a lot of
trouble as a trader is sometimes
you know i i just look at candlestick
charts and
you know after i'm having a good day i
get lazy
and i i used to take a lot of poor
trades on candlestick charts and
i still do you know sometimes you know
you get lured and you know myself
i've been training so long you know my
background i did study candlestick
charts for many years so there's certain
patterns that i look for
but when i added order flow to the
candlesticks
it really gave me insight into the
market
so out of all that activity this was the
one
place to get take a trade right here you
know i can make an
argument to take this trade but i
probably wouldn't
have because it's just such a big bar i
don't like to get short off of big bars
but yeah and it's got a big strong
negative delta so you know
at some point i'd be looking for a
little bit of a pullback and then i get
it here right i get a bar i got a single
print
five at the top of the bar i got one two
three four
five selling imbalances okay i see point
of control
it's a little bit lower okay that's to
be expected you know you got a red
candle so i'd expected
point of control to be down strong
negative delta you see
and this is right before the cash open
this morning you know this is trading
you want to trade around the 30
um 20 area right then boom cash opens
and then this bar here two bars later
and we just you know just drop like a
rock
but if i was looking at a candlestick
chart
you know it's easy to see when you see a
big bar like that i gotta get short but
then you get short what happens you pull
back into it
but this is that bar with the order flow
that was very bearish right so you get
short you know okay
fine get short here i know where my stop
is going to be right here i'm getting
short off this big candlestick chart
um you know i said you know i don't want
to put a stop way up at the top here
i want to you know sort of control it
but here you know i know i got you know
my point of control sort of right here
um you know i've got the imbalances i
got something to hide behind
right and then boom the market sells off
uh very quickly very dramatically
right right here so i've got a few
things going on
in the order flow with the small print
with the multiple cell and imbalances
obviously with the negative delta is
getting stronger you can see the deltas
here kind of
weakening 284 then 162. so
order flow analysis provides the trader
the kind of advanced information
they need to get an edge over other
traders by being able to uncover trading
opportunities
the other traders just don't see and you
know i started out saying you know these
are unusual but for
it's unusual for people that don't
understand order flow and
you know that's what's going to give you
an edge over them you know it
allows you to not over complicate
trading
right you got to trade what you see
happening right in front of you
and more importantly you trade based on
market generated information
that basically other traders are
ignoring now you know one of my
favorite quotes you know johnny carson
kids nowadays don't know who johnny
carson is but you know talent alone
won't make you a success a success
neither will being in the right place at
the right time unless you are ready
so the most important question to ask is
are you ready
and you know if you're ready you want to
add
order full analysis to your trading you
know you've come to the right place now
there's two ways you can do it
right you could spend a year or longer
looking at a screen trying to figure out
i've talked to a lot of people saying
mike i've been trying to figure out
order for the last five years i just
don't understand it can you help me
yeah i can you know don't waste a year
or more losing money trading now that's
the worst
i don't know what's worse wasting your
time trying to figure it out on your own
or wasting your money
trading trying to figure it out on your
own you know
you can spend a lot of time sim trading
but if you
open an account now you got micros you
can trade so you know the cost of
education
real time education is a lot cheaper but
you know the last thing
i don't know what's worse spending a lot
of time and not figuring it out or
losing a lot of money not figuring out
you know at the end of the day it makes
you want to you know do this
you know i hate to say it but um a lot
of traders just get frustrated at the
market
now again if you want to do it the
freeway subscribe to my youtube channel
youtube.com orderflows it's a ton of
free information on there i've got a
couple hundred videos on there
um i'm trying to get the 5 000
subscribers i'm almost there i need like
50 more
and yeah get started there that's a
great place to start now but if you want
to
you know put it on a faster track get
the education
and software from a trader who's
successfully traded order flow at the
highest level for decades
skip the massive trading losses well now
with the micros
it's just trading losses i want to say
massive and more importantly
skip the wasted time trying to figure it
out
you know success it there's like a stair
step to success right learning training
instruction
practice right and that's what i'm i'm
here to help provide you
now the order flows trader software runs
on ninjatrader eight it doesn't run on
think or swim
it doesn't run on tradestation or sierra
chart it runs on ninjatrader
and it will run on the free version of
ninjatrader as well so if you already
have like another platform like sierra
chart
for your order entry or you know another
you know trading technologies
depending on who your broker is you may
already have a free platform but
probably doesn't have good enough order
flow
analysis software for you you can get
the down you can download the free
version in
ninjatrader 8 and run my software on it
and it's the volume footprint chart
which i showed you here all right and
it's got
seven pre-programmed order flow
indicators we're going to do a major
upgrade
this summer hopefully i think it's
probably going to happen in the fall now
where we're going to add a few more
forms of analysis in the software for
you
and the upgrade is free right i don't
charge people for an upgrade
um for my software even you know people
that had it for ninjatrader seven that
want to upgrade to ninjatrader eight
it's a free upgrade right because you
know i just want you to have
you know good tools and normally i sell
it for
8.99 right and i've got to add you get
my chart template so
you can have your chart looking just
like my chart
now you know that was the part that
frustrates me on a lot of
software out there is you just download
the software
very little documentation on how to get
started i got a lot of videos
how you install it how to set up your
chart from scratch
if you want to if you don't want to use
my template because
you know at the end of the day i don't
want to get a lot of questions from you
and say i don't understand this this
that because you're just going to get
frustrated i'm going to get frustrated
that's why i created a lot of training
for you that you can get started
easily and the other thing is having
order flow software is one thing
you have to know how to use it but more
importantly you have to know what to
look for so i don't just leave your
software here is your software
go figure it out i provide a lot of
training
on how to read the order flow and
you know each week i do a private live
group training session
just for users right you can't attend
you could watch the recordings
right there's about 75 recordings you
know you could go go i'll watch them
i've got them on a page you know there's
some people out there you know if
you know they sell your software then
they sell you access to their trading
room
right 99 a month 200
a month for you know for what one hour a
week you know
here i do it for you for free so if you
got any questions
you could also you know like say mike
i'm stuck on something on on the order
flow
on the session that's where i am you
know you could reach me for sure
on that session you just go into the um
room at that time and ask your question
but i also give you other
courses you get my order flow trading
course which normally i sell it for 297.
you get it for free it's 20 lessons 15
hours of video instruction
normally i sell it for 297 you're going
to get it for free
now for a lot of traders nowadays
they've got some basic information on
order flow
but they want to sort of take it to
another level and i also give access to
the videos
of my inner circle that i used to have
and there's 56 videos in there and it's
on advanced order flow tricks tips and
analysis
okay so you start adding it up right you
get the order flow software for 8.99
training for 297 access to the inner
circle video series
for 497 plus you get access you get live
group training each week and if you
can't attend that it's all recorded for
you
but i'm also giving you a special bonus
right i mean
you know i i just want people to get
order flow
period you know that's why i give out
these
courses when you get my software the
order flow playbook which is you know
one of the courses i created which
you know is actually one of my favorite
courses because you know i had a lot of
fun making it
in the sense that it really
helped me put down a lot of my thoughts
and trade setups
you know in an easy to read format for
traders so
you know you add that overflow playbook
that's a nice i sell that you can buy
that now on my website for 297.
right so you added up the software all
the training
the live group training session you know
that's at least two thousand dollars
but again i don't want you to pay that
you know i understand you know we're in
time of
of covert 19 and a lot of people
you know are struggling to make ends
meet and
yeah i got a special offer for you so
again when i created the order fellows
trader you know my goal was to create a
better tool for analyzing the order flow
then
already was being done really all the
software that was out there
and i have this picture i laugh when i
see this picture you know except no
imposters
is because when i started releasing my
software years ago
i saw a lot of you know a lot of my
users would come to me like a few months
later saying oh you know this software
is adding
what you have on your software you know
this other software is also
trying to add it you know you go to
sierra charts you can read through the
chat board you know there's people
always asking hey can you add this
you know which is one of my um
indicators can you add that into sierra
charts
but the thing is if you don't know how
to apply it
it's not gonna be very useful to you
okay and
you know that that's why i have the
training so you could understand what
you're looking at right
and this is what other people say you
know sheila says you know your order
flows software is remarkably helpful
because i can clearly see now what's
happening in the market
like for example who's in control of the
market on a very specific time and who's
getting weaker as well
you know other comments um
you know i took your course alone one
month ago and you give a really fresh
and sane error in the field very
impressive
um you know if you really want to trade
properly and understand what on earth is
happening in any markets order flow is
the path forward
and mike's experience and explanation it
clicks
so you know to be successful it's there
you gotta go get it
right it's just not gonna magically fall
in your lap so if you're interested
in what i have you know with my software
with my training
you know for this time you know this
this time of of covet 19 i got a special
offer
675 you get the order flow software you
get
the order flows playbook you get access
to the inner circle video series
you get access to the overflow training
course you get access to the weekly live
group training sessions for just a
one-time payment of 6.75 it's not a
monthly thing i don't
keep coming after you each month give me
100 bucks or whatever
no it's you know 675 it's going to give
you a great education
and software to use for trading now you
will have to
obviously pay you know data fees and you
know
ninja trader fees if you know you're
going to trade through ninjatrader
but yeah your basic payment is 6.75 so
what you do is you go to orderflows.com
of2.html
and you're going to
see this page here okay and on this page
you know you scroll down there's there's
you know a lot of videos on there
and you know examples of trades but you
go down to the bottom of the page
okay and it says what you're going to
get here
right you just click this button buy now
you know i want this i want to get
started mike
and it takes you to paypal i don't
process your payment information i don't
get your credit card information i don't
want to deal with that stuff
it's all handled through paypal most
people are familiar with paypal
um you know it's safe it's secure it's
been around for a lot of time you know
for many years and you don't need a
paypal account
you can just click here pay with a debit
card or credit card
as well so it's simple just go to
orderflows.com
off to dot html now if you want to get
my book
okay go to orderflows.combook.html
and it's going to you have to enter your
name and email address and hit submit
okay and it's going to take you to the
page where you can download the book
to your computer to your phone or to
your tablet
and you know if you want to print it up
you're free to print it up yeah it's a
great book
it's a great resource for traders that
are interested in getting started
in order flow or you know people that
are already familiar with order flow
you know want to sort of expand their
knowledge a bit
now you know earlier i i was talking
about my youtube channel
and i can't stress this enough you know
i put videos up
um every so often and
i've got a lot of videos up there you
know because a lot of people ask me hey
you know mike can i use order flow with
forex can i use order flow with um
you know indian stocks and stuff and i
cover a lot of that stuff
in videos so yeah you're probably going
to find you know a lot of your questions
answered already in there
but um yeah if you just want to learn
more general stuff about order flow it's
a great place to start it's a great
resource
and if you subscribe every time i post a
new video you'll be alerted to
um you know when it's posted so
again you know get started go to order
flows dot com slash
off to and thank you for presenting
just real quick i'll see if there's any
questions i could get to
um okay honestly any questions
so you know what i'll end it there for
today so
you know everyone i said again you know
education is free
and in the sense that you know once you
get it
it's with you for life you know people
you know i know a lot of people
that get into trouble for a lot of
things
in in life and you know the one thing
you know because people always try and
do it you know this is kind of a i'm
sort of going off topic but
you know people how to say it you know
the one thing
you can't take away from you is your
education
things that you know you know you could
lose everything you could
lose your house to a fire or a flood
you get thrown in jail you could lose
your legs but you know they can't take
information out of your brain
so you know once you learn something
that's information you could take with
you for the rest of your life
and hopefully make money with it you
know in the sense that you can apply it
to the markets
or you know whatever you do in life so
again you know thanks for watching this
presentation thanks for taking the time
out
and again you know it's already
summertime coming up
it's the last week of may so
you know it's a great time to get
started you know if you haven't got
started already
in your trading education now is a great
time so thanks everybody have a great
day
and bye bye
uh